today on the matt walsh show statues of
historical figures are of course going
down across the country while murals and
memorials to george floyd are going up
but if we're having difficult
conversations about the sins of
of dead people that we choose to honor
isn't it time to have a conversation
like that about
george floyd what about the scrutiny for
him as we as we put up all of these
monuments and memorials to him
we'll talk about that also five
headlines and in our daily cancellation
i will be
very excited to do this i will be
finally canceling
canada the entire country of canada is
cancelled
for good reason i'll tell you why um and
all of that is coming up on the show
today
but first you know two events from
yesterday that i want to focus on
first in buffalo yet another statue of
columbus has come down it was removed
it was removed by the city this time not
the mob but it was removed by the city
at the behest of the mob which isn't
much better than the mob just doing it
themselves this of course is one of
dozens of statues of columbus to come
down in recent weeks along with the
statues of
the founders of statues of abolitionists
statues of
civil war figures etc etc etc we all
know we know what's been happening
uh by the way nancy pelosi speaking of
that quick
side note nancy pelosi the woman of such
great courage
was asked about all of these statues
coming down being torn down
and was specifically asked about whether
she thinks they should be torn down by
the mob
and then thrown into the water as has
become the tradition
for the mob and here's what she said in
response to that
i'm not one of those people who's wedded
to oh a statue
to somebody someplace is an important
thing
i don't again if the community doesn't
want the statue there the statue
shouldn't be there
i doesn't diminish my pride in my
italian-american heritage and the fact
that
it was a country discovered by an
italian name
for an italian america's beauty so
i have that pride but i don't care that
much about statues
respectfully shouldn't that be done by a
commission or the city council not a mob
in the middle of the night throwing it
into the harbor
will do what they do people will do what
they do
well okay then i if people will do what
they do then i guess that's that's all
that can be said
never mind i guess it's fine people are
going to do what they do
it's better for people to do what they
do than do what they don't do that would
be confusing i guess
meanwhile in rochester rochester
minnesota i believe
a mural of george floyd was unveiled
there's an image from the post bulletin
of the of the mural being unveiled
in a ceremony uh this is one of many uh
murals of floyd around the country while
while the statues are coming down the
murals honoring floyd are going up
sometimes one
directly replacing the other like
floyd's face was actually projected onto
a monument
in richmond a few weeks ago you could
see the image there and there have been
many other murals honoring the great man
uh here are just a few compiled by cnbc
this is worldwide too most of the murals
are in the united states but some are in
other countries around the globe
and it's not just murals they've they've
got laws named after him
they've got streets named after him
unofficially right now but eventually
i'm sure will be officially
there's even a bust of george floyd that
you can
3d print for your own home if you're
looking for some home decor you can get
a bust of george floyd
and they're looking at potentially
naming business or naming buildings
after him as well
like this building at auburn university
for example
now it should be noted of course that
all of this is being done
just like the golden casket the multiple
funerals the memorial services
everything it's being done explicitly to
honor
and celebrate the man george floyd
democrats kneeled in silence for eight
minutes to honor they gave a folded
american flag
to his family members i don't know if
you heard about that one uh
that's what they do for fallen soldiers
and they they gave a folded american
flag
people even go to the site of you can
see the footage here of george floyd's
death
to be baptized and and to mourn his
loss so
given all of this uh given the dichotomy
here
where we have the tearing down the
statues of historical figures and icons
because of the bad stuff they did while
putting up memorials to george floyd
i think it becomes relevant to discuss
the bad things that
he did is this in fact
a man worthy of honor because we're not
just talking about his death
we're not talking about uh whether his
death was was justified that's in the
courts now the police have
that involved have long since been
arrested so this is way beyond that
we are meant to celebrate and honor the
man himself
and since we have uh
you know declared that that the the the
sins of the
of the of the dead people we honor are
relevant
then it's also relevant for him and
we're going to talk more about that
in just a second but first a word from a
new sponsor i'm very excited about car
shield
you know it can be pretty terrifying if
you if you have car trouble so
you know there's a problem with your car
and you bring it into the mechanic
and you're just waiting with baited
breath to find out how expensive it's
going to be
and oftentimes it's even worse than you
imagine computer systems and cars are
the new normal from electronically
controlled transmissions to touch screen
displays to dozens of sensors
but you can't fix any of these new
features yourself that's part of the
problem they're great to have
can't fix them so when something breaks
it could cost a fortune and now is not
the time for expensive repairs i think
we all feel that way that's why i have
car shield car shield i can't recommend
it enough has offered affordable
protection plans
that can save you thousands for a
covered repair including computers gps
electronics and more i mean this thing's
a lifesaver
the people at car shield understand
payment flexibility is an absolute must
so monthly plans can be customized
customized to your needs with rates as
low as 99 a month
no long-term contracts no commitments
car shield gives you options others
won't you get to choose your favorite
mechanic or dealership to do
the work car shield takes care of the
rest so they're taking a lot of that off
your plate um
and you don't have to worry about the
expense you don't have to worry about
anything
it's just it's for me you know having
car shield has really been
a matter of peace of mind that i know
that you know when i've got a problem
with one of the cars
that we're gonna we're to have we're
going to have that taken care of
and you know then you just go about
living your life for as low as 99
a month you can protect yourself from
surprises and save thousands for a
covered repair
call 800 car 6000 and mention
code walsh or visit carshield.com and
use codewalls to save ten percent that's
car shield.com codewalsh
a deductible may apply all right um
so as as we're talking about the sins of
of people long dead
[Music]
or maybe not so long dead
what about george floyd well
here's the image that a lot of you have
probably seen this is floyd's rap sheet
and you could see there theft theft
possession
trespassing lots of crimes there but
it's the one at the top the aggravated
robbery with a deadly weapon that really
jumps out
and you've heard something about this
probably
but maybe you don't know all the details
so let me let me read the details to you
and this i'm reading from
snopes by the way which is a left-wing
outlet in an article that is meant
largely to debunk
the anti-george floyd sentiments such as
they are
so that's where i'm getting this from
okay this is not a it's not a not i'm
not a biased
not a right wing bias source it says
according to police officers probable
cause statement
which is often the basis of prosecutors
case cases against suspects
the incident which is the robbery on
august 9th 2007 unfolded like this two
adults
uh era racely henriquez and angel
negrate and a toddler were in a home
when they heard a knock at the front
door
when henriquez looked at the window she
saw a man dressed in a blue uniform who
said he was there to with the water
department
but when she opened the door she
realized the man was telling a lie and
she tried shutting him out
then the statement reads however this
male
held the door open and prevented her
from doing so at this time a black ford
explorer pulled up in front of the
complainant's
residence and five other black males
exited this vehicle and proceeded to the
front door
the largest of these suspects forced his
way into the residence placed a pistol
against the complainant's abdomen
and forced her into a living room area
of the residence this large suspect then
proceeded to search the residence while
another armed suspect guarded the
complainant who was struck in the head
in side areas by this second armed
suspect
with his pistol after she screamed for
help as the suspects looked through the
residence they demanded to know where
the drugs and money were and complainant
henriquez
advised them that there were no such
things in the residence the suspects
then took some jewelry along with the
complainant's cell phone before they
fled the scene
in the black ford explorer about three
months later investigators in the
houston police department narcotics unit
came across this vehicle during one of
their respective investigations
and uh and identified the following
subjects as occupants of the vehicle
george floyd at six foot seven floyd was
i that floyd was identified as the
largest of the six suspects who arrived
at the home
and uh that's how they know that he's
the one who he uh
put the pistol against henriquez's
stomach he pled guilty in 2009
was sentenced to five years in prison
was paroled in 2013.
okay so this is a man who forced his way
into a woman's house
put a gun to her stomach in front of her
child um
and robbed her and it seems like
you know i don't know all the specifics
of the plea bargain but he got a hell of
a deal on this thing
you know he should he should still he
should still be alive because he'd still
be in prison
this is a home invasion robbery
there should be a kidnapping charge
attached to this you hold a gun to
someone's stomach
hold them captive that's kidnapping so
uh he got you he served five years in
prison for that all right
the woman was pistol-whipped in the
process
this is not just a minor misdemeanor
this is not a little scrape with the law
this is an act of barbaric
evil
it's not some small thing that you could
say oh yeah you know you had a record
but it's
you go into a woman's house when their
child is there put a
gun to their stomach can you imagine how
traumatized this woman still is
how traumatized would you be if that
happened to you
i mean this is this is her feelings of
safety and security are taken away for
the rest of her life
you know you don't get over something
like that
had floyd reformed himself at the time
of of his death that's what we're told
well he was high on meth and fentanyl
trying to pass off counterfeit money
that's how that's what precipitated
the arrest and eventually his death so
there's not much evidence for
reformation i'm afraid
but whether he was or wasn't the fact is
that he committed these evil
horribly horrifically evil acts
is that not a relevant consideration
again this isn't about assessing
the death itself this is about the
things that are being done to honor
and celebrate the man there is just no
evidence that there was
anything honorable about him
and unlike some of our historical
figures like jefferson who did evil
things yes but also achieved great
things
floyd it doesn't appear ever achieved
anything greater noteworthy whatsoever
he doesn't seem to have done much
constructive with his life and if he did
i think the damage that he caused was
far greater than
than whatever good he did and you could
just ask the woman that he robbed
which by the way how many media members
have done that how many of these
courageous truth seekers in the media
who are so concerned about uh
about amplifying the voices of the
marginalized marginalized
how many of them have gone to this woman
miss enriquez and asked her how she
feels
about murals and memorials to the to the
to the man who put a gun to her stomach
and robbed her in front of her kids
you want to talk about about things that
are triggering about things that
bring trauma to mind what about that
how does she feel i don't know where she
lives now but
if she lives in a city where there's one
of these murals how do you think she
feels walking by it
a mural a memorial honoring the man who
put a gun to your stomach in your house
and robbed you
is her perspective not important
shouldn't we shouldn't we listen to what
she has to say
what we seem to be saying now is that
men should be honored
not based on what they achieved in life
but based on how they died and
more specifically based on how useful
their death is to the left-wing
narrative that's what this is really
about
you throw everything else to the side
but that's just not that doesn't make
any sense
that's that's perverse and that's
backwards
and and here's the thing as i've said
all along
i am perfectly open to having
conversations the
quote-unquote difficult conversations
about historical figures people who have
died
uh you know the bad things they did
let's have a more nuanced perspective on
them
okay let's not make uh let's not deify
people
mere mortals of the past let's let's
let's confront the bad things they did
let's try to get uh a fuller and more
complete picture of them i'm all about
that
unfortunately of course right now that's
not what any of this is about this is
not an
environment where we can have that kind
of conversation the people that are
tearing down monuments and statues
they are interested in that they're not
you don't tear down a statue set it on
fire and throw it in the bay
because you want to have a nuanced
conversation about the about the
historical figure whose statue you just
torn down
that's that's not that's not what's
happening here but in a in a
you know in a fantasy scenario i would
be all about having those kinds of
conversations but
if we're going to have that conversation
nobody is exempt
george floyd is not exempt
and especially if you're among the
people
who are in favor of tearing down the
statues
because of the of the the evil that was
either actually done
or allegedly done by these by these
figures
and yet you also support or have
yourself put up murals and memorials
to george floyd then you should have to
justify that you should have to confront
these evil things
that he did and explain
how he is still worthy of being honored
and celebrated which for the for the
fifth time that's what this is
so don't tell me that yeah he did these
bad things that doesn't mean he deserved
to die
that's not the point that's not what i'm
saying
i'm saying that from from looking at his
biography and the things that he that he
did
i don't see any reason to honor or
celebrate
the man
just just let's just take a hypothetical
here just to
uh just to under underscore my point
imagine that there was a white guy
killed by police
unarmed and this is not this is not some
far-fetched scenario white people are
killed by police
more often than black people are uh
unarmed white people too so
take one of those cases of an unarmed
white person being killed by police
um and then
not now here here's the part where we
get to the far-fetched scenario let's
let's just say that there was actually
outrage and protests over it
and people were putting up murals and
memorials to this man now that's never
going to happen because we don't do that
for white people
who are killed by cops we just ignore
them for the most part completely
but let's just say that was happening
and then let's say that it came out
that this person was an avowed racist
we don't even have to imagine that he
actually committed violent crimes like
george floyd did let's just say he was
in a vowed races let's say that he was
you know comes out that he was active in
on on white supremacist websites and
he's a lot of
social media postings talking about the
supremacy of the white race and all that
kind of stuff
um is there any doubt whatsoever
that everyone on the left would be
saying
take down the murals take down the
memorials we're not going to honor and
celebrate this guy
yes perhaps his death was unjustified
but this is not someone who can we can
honor and celebrate given what sort of
man he was
is there any doubt about that whatsoever
any doubt no
is is uh but is is
barging into a woman's home and robbing
her at gunpoint is that is that is that
not as bad as
racist social media postings let's say
of course not
or of course it is worse um
it's a violent crime against a victim
who you have left
traumatized for life and who now
again has to live seeing your likeness
and your face
everywhere as people celebrate you as if
you were some great man
let's move on to headlines before we do
i want to tell you about very good
friends rock otto
um you know i i personally would be fine
if i never had to go to a auto parts
store
again it's just uh it's a huge hassle
you could never find exactly what you're
looking for
uh plus you get peppered with all the
questions and you know if you're someone
like me not exactly a car
expert that can be very you know that
could get a little dicey because i don't
want i don't want to reveal that i don't
know exactly what i'm what i'm doing
rockauto.com is so much easier though
because you just go online you're not
being harassed by anybody
you can find everything you're looking
for um rockauto.com is always offered
the lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do
rockauto.com you know it's a family
business even though it's an online
business it's a family business it's
been doing this for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all the prices of rockauto.com
are always reliably low
uh you know that's best of all second
best of all i think is that
the great selection as well the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your car
truck
choose the brands choose the
specifications choose the prices you
prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices if
you need anything for your car
truck um you've got it at your
fingertips all the time it's in your
pocket just pull
out your phone go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck right walsh in there how did
you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you okay
we begin
um here a few weeks ago a man named
robert
fuller was found hanging from a tree in
southern california
and this precipitated weeks of
speculation by the media fire stoking by
democrats in the left
protests the left speculated or just
openly outright stated
that fuller was witched
despite the fact that the police right
away said that this is suicide and they
could tell because
police respond unfortunately to a lot of
suicide suicide's very common in this
country becoming more common
and uh it's usually easy to determine
and
differentiate a suicide from a murder
most of the time
you know a suicide scene in a murder
scene do not look the same most of the
time especially to police who do this
kind of thing all the time
and yet we were still told no this is
probably a lynching
well in response to the outrage police
did a more thorough investigation i
think
they did the kind of investigation where
they went further than they would for
any other suicide
um but they did and here were their
findings from the daily news it says the
death of a black man found hanging from
a tree in a southern california city
last month was ruled a suicide um
los angeles county sheriff alex vela
nueva promised a thorough investigation
at a news conference to announce the
findings
it was revealed that fuller had a
history of mental illness and suicidal
tendencies
sheriff's commander chris marks outlined
three hospitalizations since 2017
where fuller told doctors he was
considering taking his life
the last was in november when he was
being treated for depression at a
hospital in nevada
and said that he had a plan to kill
himself um
marx also said that there was an
investigation into an incident where
fuller allegedly tried to light himself
on fire
um also and this is important i don't
think it's covered in this article but
fuller used an ebt
card to buy the very rope that was used
in the hanging
okay so as conclusive there was there
was no signs of a struggle to begin with
his hands were not bound no signs that
anything
occurred against his will it's open and
shut
case closed very sad story tragic
not a story of a murder there was never
any reason to think so and there were a
lot of very
clear reasons to think otherwise
especially now
but but you notice how the family
said that they can't imagine that fuller
would have killed himself
meanwhile he was hospitalized three
times because he was thinking about
killing himself
he tried to set himself on fire a few
months ago allegedly
did the family not know about that
uh was was was fuller really that
depressed that self-destructive his
family didn't know
no i i don't know and i you know i i
certainly don't blame them for what he
did but i wonder why
i wonder why they were speculating about
murder if he was so
obviously depressed and suicidal and
someone who's hospitalized three times
in three years
with suicidal thoughts that's someone
who
very very clearly has suicidal
tendencies and is
struggling uh you know with with with
many
internal struggles in any case put his
family aside
the behavior from the media and the
democrats on the left
was just grotesque and disgusting and
soulless
they were all more than happy to take
advantage of this tragic situation for
their own ends
these are you know this is truly evil
behavior
again there was never any reason to
speculate
that this was anything other than a
suicide
the idea that someone could have been
could have been lynched
by a literal lynch mob in public
and nobody witnessed it and there's no
video or anything
and no evidence left behind is
patently ludicrous now i believe that
some of the people
in the outrage mob someone just you know
some of them might be dumb enough to
actually think that that's possible
but elected democrats like camilla
harris for example who was talking about
this and speculating
especially someone like her who's who
you know is familiar
with law enforcement she knows better
they they all knew better
and yet they were stoking this fire
anyway
if they had a soul i would say they
should feel shame but they don't so
they won't number two here's a video of
what
guts really looks like not literal guts
i'm not you know this is not a
video of someone who's been disemboweled
i mean you have to clarify those sorts
of things these days no
this is what courage looks like i should
say bravery uh here you go
[Applause]
okay
that's bold okay walking into a mob like
that
with that sign that's great that's
savannah hernandez by the way that's her
name uh credits
where it's due awesome awesome stuff
there number three i wanted to mention
this
maybe you've seen uh the video footage
this is philip banks
former wide receiver retired military
caught up caught a baby that was tossed
30 feet out of a burning building
in phoenix if you haven't seen it watch
the footage here
that's harrowing footage heroic effort
by uh
mr banks there and uh the reason i'm
playing this and i've seen this all over
the internet you probably have already
seen it i i think it's not being
emphasized enough
if you have seen this maybe you haven't
even heard this part of the story that
the the baby was thrown from the burning
building by the mother
who saved the baby's life the mother did
not make it out she died in the fire
uh and she apparently died because as i
understand it she was going she went
back into the flames to retrieve her
daughter
who she didn't realize had already been
rescued by a neighbor
and she uh you know presumably was
overcome by
by smoke inhalation and and she died so
yeah it's a completely tragic story
but also and and banks
who caught the child is a hero in this
story and
and you know he's awesome but the the
ultimate hero of the story
who i think we should talk about
honoring people should be honored is the
mother who gave her life for her
children
you know that's that is a tragic yet
beautiful example of motherly love so
i wanted to play that for you number
four bill de blasio was on with wolf
blitzer yesterday when
he explained okay so we'll go from the
ultimate of courage to the ultimate of
gutless cowardice and that's
bill de blasio was was on cnn he
explained that
new york needs to go back into a full
lockdown no large gatherings of any kind
with one exception can you guess what
the exception is
so describe large events for us what
does what does that mean
it means like street fairs it means you
know big outdoor
concerts and it means things like
parades you know things that
here in the city can mean not just
thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people it's
just not time for that now
what about protests if people want to
march down fifth avenue are they going
to be allowed to do so
look wolf this is always an area of real
sensitivity if you're just talking about
health we would always say hey folks you
know stay home if you can but
we understand at this moment in history
people are talking about the need for
historic
changes i mean today in new york city
you know
recognizing the power and the meaning of
the message black lives matter which we
did in front of trump tower today
this is a historic moment of change we
have to respect that but also say to
people
the the kinds of gatherings we're used
to the the parades the fairs
we just can't have that while we're
focusing on health right now
not that this matters anymore but that
is just blatantly unconstitutional that
is viewpoint discrimination
you you cannot do that you can't tell
people that they're only allowed to
gather if they're expressing this or
that point of view that
that's a just quintessential violation
of the constitution there's there's no
discussion to be had
i it would be hard to think of a more
blatant violation of the first amendment
than that
but he they're he's doing it anyway and
and that's the thing you see that
we we can shout and scream that
something is unconstitutional
those in power are just going to do it
anyway and that's what's happening in
new york
five finally here's footage out of
florida
giant stingrays are seen swimming by
unsuspecting
beachgoers and you know
you you you see that and you think okay
well there's the stingrays
it's a pretty big stingrays that's cool
you know wow look at those
and those are big stingrays so that's
pretty cool stuff interesting
but then you see wait a second what they
buried the lead there
what is that is that hellboy is that
is that satan himself swimming in the
ocean is that some kind of
mutant human tomato half breed
no that's a that's a person that's a
full person
with the worst sunburn of all time that
is a 33rd degree sunburn
that he has his skin has melted off his
body i don't even
that's not even his skin that's that's
just that's the insides of him
he looks like he fell into a vat of v8
juice or something
the worst batman villain of all time
fell into a vat of
v8 jews look at that my god
i thought i got bad sunburns i burned
pretty easily
this dude's not gonna be able to take a
hot shower until like next march
sometime
my goodness wear your sunscreen kids
wear the sunscreen i'm a hypocrite
because i rarely wear it myself
because i i just enjoy the pain i guess
masochist i don't know but wear your
sunscreens that's
that's the that's the real message there
now we're going to get to our daily
cancellation it's a very important one
as i
will set out to finally cancel the
entire country of canada
long overdue before we do that we've
been telling you about our new sponsors
at blink sale
uh revolutionary invoicing software
that's changing the landscape for small
businesses and independent contractors
everywhere
you know the quintessential american
dream of course is owning a business
building a successful business
and you know having the opportunity the
freedom to be your own boss is a
is an amazing thing but as many business
owners know there are so many moving
parts
it can be hard to manage everything even
the things that seem small
can become big hassles and can really
interfere with the efficiency of your
business
big part of that is invoicing you know
if you've ever had to harass
a client who owes you money or you've
gotten lost trying to keep track of your
invoice and payments
you've been trying to deal with those
maybe you just have some form
some microsoft you know uh
[Music]
thing that you use for your invoices all
of that can be
a huge hassle that's why you need blink
sale with blink cell you can send
beautiful custom branded invoices and
estimates in seconds you can stay on top
of your outstanding
invoices you can let your customers and
clients easily pay your invoices online
as an added bonus blink sales giving
away 10
to 500 daily wire fans here's how you
get to go to blinksail.com
start your 14 day free trial create your
first invoice of 10
and activate an online payment option
send the invoice to dailywire
blinksale.com and you get paid your 10.
the first 500
people to send an invoice of uh for ten
dollars to daily wire
at blink sale will get their invoice
paid by blink sale limit of one per
person stop wasting time
invoicing and try blink sale for free at
blink sale dot com slash walsh that's b
l i n k s a l e dot com slash walsh
blink sale spend less time billing and
more time
doing what you love and we appreciate
blink cell just like we appreciate all
of our sponsors uh during
this you know during this time who have
stuck with us and uh
and helped keep us afloat and we
appreciate all of you who
listen to us you know tell you about our
sponsors and uh if you
hear something that sounds like you need
uh you know we we appreciate you
supporting those sponsors and thereby
supporting us
um let's go to our daily cancellation
as i said canceling canada whole country
canceled abolished
i've had enough i've had enough of
canada i
uh just and let me just say i do blame
the entire country of canada
and all of its inhabitants for what
you're about to see here
i want to show you a message from the
west vancouver pd
this is what the west vancouver pd is
worried about this is what they're
working on
okay it says here's the tweet it says
investigators would like to speak with
the driver responsible for defacing a
recently installed
pride crosswalk at 16th street and
esquimalt avenue
if you have information please call and
there's the phone number
and then you could you could see the
pictures of the horrific defacement
the hate crime perpetrated on the
crosswalk
crosswalk lives matter i guess and you
see there tire tracks
tire marks tire marks on a road
a road someone drove on a road
which which which is a thing that that
exists to be driven on
and this is a hate crime now in canada
excuse me
not a hate crime a hate gesture
that's that's the exact phrase the
vancouver pdus they said it's a gesture
of hate
now um as part of their investigation
they provide this this chilling video
footage
of the driver driving on the road uh
look you can see it here there he is
you see that wow there's a driver
driving on the road they actually
actually published this video footage
and we're supposed to be horrified by
this a guy driving on a road
and look at that it's even worse the
road is black okay
the man is driving on a black road
and but you notice something this is
this is worse than we even thought
this is not just anti-gay discrimination
this is also a racial thing
he drives on the pride crosswalk he
drives on the black road
what isn't he driving on notice that the
sidewalk
which is what color white
is this just a coincidence that this
person happens to decide hey i'm gonna
drive on the rainbow thing
and then the black thing not the white
thing
that's i think we need this is we need
to execute the torture and execute him
then leave his head on a stake at the at
the entrance to the city
with a sign this is what we do to bigots
in this town
anyway um the local media also got in on
the act to track down the hate
gesture that video i just played was
posted by a local reporter who
encouraged everyone to call the police
if they had any
any information any information again
specifically about a person driving on a
road
uh the vancouver sun had an article with
this headline
west vancouver's pride crosswalk
vandalized
another local news outlet said
tiremark's tarnish new pride crosswalk
in west vancouver
and this isn't just happening in
vancouver okay i went down the canada
rabbit hole i went down the canada hole
which i i don't recommend doing
and i discovered that this happens a lot
in canada
okay there are multiple cases of this
where they paint rainbows on the road
and then
cry when someone drives on them here's
an article from
the town of prescott um from the the
website
ottawamatters.com
the headline vandalism to rainbow
crosswalk further proof of
need for pride prescott mayor
it says an act of vandalism on a rainbow
crosswalk and prescott has pride
organizer ryan robert northup
disappointed but he has faith the town
will learn
i do think small town communities have a
hard time accepting these things he said
but i think that communities do come
around
only only hours after the town
approximately 80
kilometers south of ottawa repainted the
rainbow crosswalk and raised the pride
flag
the symbol was defaced for a second time
in as many years
why does this keep happening i can't
figure out i mean we keep painting stuff
on the road and the next thing you know
they're tire marks on it i cannot
why is this happening dear god why are
you doing this to us
why us the crosswalkers were painted at
4 pm and by 7 pm black tire marks
streaked across the symbol ann collins
spokesperson for the opp
uh yeah you know me confirmed in an
email police
police are investigating the incident
matthew markell
who grew up in prescott but now lives in
toronto was one of the first people to
discover
the act of vandalism he said it really
makes me upset and it really makes a lot
of other people upset
that people are still willing to take
time out of their day to destroy
something
that's supposed to be celebrating
equality and celebrating pride
prescott mayor brett todd referred to
the act as a hate crime
and said that this is a further proof
for the necessity of events like pride
uh and then it goes on for there and
they they're
now they're talking about let me say in
terms of additional preventative
measures
uh they're talking about installing
cameras around the the crosswalk so
so this is what this is how they're
spending their time in canada they are
they are
painting rainbows on the road which is
already dumb enough
okay we could stop right there that's
cancelable on its own
painting rainbows on the road for gay
pride it's already cancellable uh
is incredibly stupid as it is but
painting rainbows on the road and then
across the country
people drive over them and then they cry
and now so now what they're gonna do
rather than just like painting the
rainbow somewhere else that isn't on the
road
now they're going to paint the rainbow
on the road to put cameras around it
so they can figure out what's happening
how does this keep happening
you know i often say that we're
surrounded by lunatics which we are
and even though i'm canceling canada and
abolishing it and evicting it from the
solar system
i know that it's far too late to contain
the crazy we should have gone into a
lockdown decades ago to contain the
crazy but it's too late it's endemic
it's uh
and i know that but looked at another
way this isn't crazy at all actually
it's outrageous it's ridiculous it's
stupid it's many other things but it's
not crazy
you might argue because there's a very
specific goal in mind
doing something like putting a rainbow
on the road and then accusing people of
a hate crime for driving on it
what's the real point of that if it's
not literal pure lunacy
okay what what would be the point well i
think the point
is control it's submission it's
obedience it's conditioning
it really reminds me and this is an
analogy that i draw a lot because
for good reason i think that they're you
know
unfortunately the analogy just is often
um often appropriate but it reminds me
of stories out of the soviet union
especially during the stalin years where
there would be just these totally
arbitrarily
arbitrary uh or seemingly arbitrary
rules
and you could be punished for doing
things that seemed completely innocent
and innocuous
and the reason for that was submission
getting the public condition to the idea
that they can't just do anything they
want without express permission
you know you can't go out there and
ad-lib you can't be freestyling when you
go about your daily life
you must not operate freely you have to
stick to the script
always at all times you have to have
permission to do everything you do
you're constantly under surveillance
you're constantly being
uh judged and and and uh you know you
have to conform at all times so this is
about conformity and obedience
submission control conditioning that's
what all this is about
so on one level we can laugh about it
and we have to laugh about it
in order to remain sane ourselves but on
another level this is actually nefarious
what they're doing
and because the only other explanation
aside from nefariousness
is that these are actual verifiable
certifiable
lunatics who are mentally delusional
and should be in insane asylums and i i
know it's very tempting to see it that
way and
and i and i talk that way sometimes uh
because it is so tempting but i think
uh you know i think it's worse than that
you know
i would prefer to think that half of the
world is just is just literal lunatics
than the other option which is that this
is all calculated
and i think that's more so the reality
all right we will leave it there i guess
have a great weekend everybody enjoy
yourselves if possible
talk to you next week godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there